che cos'è questo ma potevo sta così se
la sicurezza delle favelas mi sento
milani e tra un po vicino a tramp hinson
melania trump e tu sei trump vorrei
morire piuttosto che stare qui tu lo
vedi che se continua a spostare questo
qua ma tu lo vedi invece questo capo che
è collegato direttamente all'inferno la
faccia del cavo stadio tavolino
vi prego datemi spazio non posso
cucinare in queste condizioni no
[Risate]
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti ad una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi ho il
piacere immenso piacere qui con me un
fratello un punto di riferimento quando
si dice roma si pensa a due cose claudio
di biagio e guglielmo scilla possiamo
dirlo né l'umiltà che ci
contraddistingue il resto è andato a
milano non aver subito dopo c'è totti e
alberto sordi e giulio cesare a roma si
mette fornelli nella creazione di un
piatto tipico l'amatriciana vogliamo
dare una versione triceht che non è
manco da roma poi è un piatto che sia io
che claudio non sappiamo fare
millantiamo è però di saper fare perché
claudio appena gliel'ho chiesto io la
porta o cotto per tutta quanta la
nazionale dalla
lazio bloccata proprio pochi giorni fa
mi è stato detto ammazza ed a ristorante
e mangiato però pure de merda e
ristorante questo è vero claudio è un
vantaggio perché cucinerà nella sua
cucina quello che voi vedete qui questa
cucina meravigliosa ricostruita
all'interno degli studios di casa sua in
realtà era la mia ci lega ancora di più
con questo la rottura è stato
protagonista di un amatriciana papa da
francesco il mio amico niente popò di
meno che per barbieri che sono chiari i
miei amici e bruno barbieri che
come funzionerà oggi abbiamo due box io
e claudio anche se stiamo facendo
effettivamente lo stesso piatto abbiamo
richiesto i nostri ingredienti segreto
quindi formato di pasta scopriremo
adesso quali sono le scelte che abbiamo
fatto non credo che erano stati presi
tutti gli strumenti che i tuoi chiesto
sono stati lesi tutti i mari quando
grazie al regista
secondo me modo della produzione per
mettermi in svantaggio già
perfetto
mappe pareggio guarda come sta mio dio
io devo tagliare sui fornelli ma che sia
chiaro io a claudio lo piazzato col
fornelletto da campeggio e che questo è
il suo lato preferito no perché sono uno
strumento verso come singola cosa che
non può scappare in vista
non è il momento di crisi
e chi non li ha chiesti io ho chiesto
tutto aiuto cazzo
sale zucchero 1 mika riscriverò esatto
gli studi richiesto
il terrore negli occhi di guglielmo
scilla viaggia tutti
arriva non c'è il cazzo qua dentro
dai prendi lo ho visto
vedere che cosa e chi no no è sale
grosso sembra per tempo però il sale
grosso
appena basta
vediamo se claudio consente ad artisti
amici pensare
per averlo dovrà pregarmi come un
orgoglio che mi divora e preferisco e
nere rancore nei confronti della
produzione visto a me l'hanno detto e
tipo masterchef non è tipo masterchef un
po imbarazzo quindi
la gara questa pasta si fa senza acqua
senza acqua io me ne vado fate la sfida
solo claudio di biagio ho vinto la sfida
si ragazzi io me ne vado c'è proprio non
era minimamente di fare quando
l'ascensore perché è molto più comodo
da quanti anni siamo non c'erano siamo
co
ma per farti disegni c'è per fare questa
edizione che continuiamo a mangiare
questa pasta che sto facendo questa la
decisione dipende da quante persone sta
recando il culo a me sembra tutta la
sala quindi 12345 prendi questo sale
grosso
questo cazzo di sale grosso
non superati no ragazzi non sono pirati
anch'io ho detto che la di polpa io vi
ammazzo nei sei ancora dalla parte loro
è ancora vicina che 12 io sto con te
come draco malfoy harry potter quando
devono comunque sconfiggere voldemort a
questa parte abbastanza easy
ma cosa stai facendo
siamo qui a ritrovarci io sto sudando
come
davvero che mi serve sposare
ma è dato di sapere qua sotto cioè come
funzionava anche perché noi non è
arrivato un regolamento di questa gara
quindi non sappiamo come ditemi voi
che la cosa che mi ha fatto molto
piacere quando ho fatto la mia
amatriciana qualche settimana fa è a
torino ai torinesi che hanno detto era
nel ristorante no avevo una platea
veramente tipo i progetti però nel box
super fine dopo tanto assaggiamo quindi
stai zitto a torino la macellaia di
fiducia da un po di tempo tutti cercano
il guanciale per fare le paste romane ed
è una cosa che prima invece non era che
spreco
cosa che fra loro
le bistecche del guanciale ok e di
servizio gli strumenti di cucina che non
conosco e non so lo so
allora io qua intanto
se magari grazie a quello scatto ex
claudio vuoi anche non lo so è un sugo
pronto ad es stampa a cura di restando
storia vera
serena zia di sarah
non riesco a guidare guanciale questo è
totalmente esterrefatto da quello che
sta succedendo che non riesco ad
abbassare gli occhi mi dire quando
accolto per favore avvicinarmi un
attimino per vedere ma non riesco a
guardare
proprio scuci nando il sugo di guglielmo
è un amen merda su chi non potrà entrare
codice
mai capire dirigo non prende più i miei
diritti
7 quando vinci e l'altro scompare dal
mio inquadrature vincitore al claudio e
nel frattempo nessuno sa che fine ha
fatto quell'altro deve coprire lo
schermo con una mano una parte molto
importante
ranieri pelati coleman e o parola sempre
versare messosi a canzoni
[Musica]
il guanciale è stufato non ci metto pure
proprio non ce non ci metto più niente
zuppa al pomodoro giusto per presente
quando consigli il compito in bianco
vestito
vogliamo fare così cambiamo le diventi
mio assistente
posso dirti che mi conviene sbagliato
si
no
per tempo
anche il controllo di questo fuoco devo
essere sincero
colpa non è colpa mia
in generale
sono al controllo di questo questo fuoco
e
credo di avere ereditato da mia nonna se
la capacità di spider man a che cosa
stai facendo risulta tura completa ma è
l'unico modo da quando ho sbattuto la
salsa di pomodori e voglio una color
grigia qui perchè l'hai fatto perché ero
con così tanti casi nella testa e l'ho
preso l'ho buttato dentro è stato un
prezzo un ecco perché e vi dirò a questa
cosa masterchef fanno [ __ ] agli chef
i concorrenti così sbagliano
ciao
[Applauso]
pecorino grattugiato possa avere un
piatto è il più simile a un cesso e la
mia pasta si è scotta scusami fratello
tempo vi qua
l'odore c'è futuro
così
un altro un tappe della flaminia fallo
vero veloce per te hai preso pure della
pancetta brava brava
tieniti chiaro concerto perfora
[Musica]
di nulla di nulla
9 scuola riccardino della vita dove ad
antonelli
brigati io ti denuncio mai ascoltare
questo passo è rimasta teme la subito
creativo mantecare io ho solo una grande
clinica da parte la pasta che amico
ragazzo la prova che c'erano
questo stiamo l'abbiamo fatto quella
comprato
[Applauso]
bellissimo
a me non facevi così con la testa quando
una stagione
l'odore 2 la quota non c'è della
porchetta normale
ai restanti la croccantezza tail del gas
vulcanici
silenzio consapevole parere dei giudici
facciamo anche le beato
ragazzi ci siamo confrontati non è vero
ho riscontrato problematica in entrambe
le parte c'è una chiaramente molto più
ti piace come nascondere tutto per
l'attenzione della scena una delle due
lo diremo
lanciare pagare il sugo fa cacare la
pasta 28 la natura se invece questa qui
ottimo sugo anche se il problema è la
colpa secondo me è un po crudo lo facevi
per meno persone meno tempo sul fuoco la
tua generosità che ha fregato claudio la
pasta fa cacare anche io prego il
rigatone malga livello di cottura ho
pianto lacrime amare per i tempi che
possiamo rivederlo un secondo quelli che
mi hanno ancora legati la vita dove dare
ancora lì
in questa sfida quale
vince
grazie
a due problemi di questa basta sono
mirror il problema è la cultura della
pasta che purtroppo va beh vediamo
il sud la colpa non era proprio ok però
è molto bello poter assaggiare la
croccantezza del guanciale comunque se
volete fare amatriciana seguite il
procedimento di claudio con i pelati
saluto a tutti i pelati se sei pelato
condividi questo video proprio per
salvarci dal problema dei pelati che non
abbiamo avuto mangiare andiamo
assolutamente a mangiare di noi tv pazzo
la tua da un
[Musica]
caso ma scusa
[Applauso]
[Musica]